all right let's talk election though cuz
I gotta get some election stuff at you
so what you do you are you a
conservative do you if you had to align
one way or another do you consider
yourself a conservative well here's the
thing about me that that's funny I did
love line for a million years and going
back you know twenty years ago and all I
said was hey if you can't afford kids
don't have kids and if you do have kids
you make them breakfast and you know and
and also said things like pot should be
legal like I should build a girl pot
plant my backyard I'm not hurting anyone
if I it's I'm paying taxes it's my land
i theorize I wanna plant now if the
government catches me opening up a
marijuana stand next to the kids
lemonade stand then you may intervene
but as long as I'm on my property and
this is my plant and I'm using this
plant like I would use scotch or vodka
then I don't see what the deal is so gay
marriage do what you want
pot smoke out it's all I've ever said
and nobody ever called me a conservative
or Republican or anything close to
anything when all I said was get a job
pay your taxes don't count on the
government if you have kids raise your
own kids the biggest problem we have is
stupid people [ __ ] out kids who
can't afford those kids the biggest
problem we have is broken families it's
who's filling up the prisons who's in
rehab
who's falling between the cracks who are
all these people that are working at
McDonald's and their 30s you know what I
mean like how are these people supposed
to raise a family of $19 21 you're not
yeah worked at McDonald's I was in the
tenth grade I worked there for one
summer I realize it sucked I got two
dollars and 80 cents an hour and I got
out of that right so some people are
gonna say there's this subtext of what
you're saying that somehow that there's
something racial in what you're saying
not saying but I know when people say
the things that you're talking about
there's somehow like this feeling like
there's some racial element well here's
the deal you can go
I don't like terrorism and then you can
go oh that's anti-muslim well if they
are it getting back to Cecil if they're
committing the lion's share of the
terrorist attacks then yes but I'm
saying I don't like poverty I like
education
I don't like broken families I don't
like people living off the grid and
having to use these check cashing places
I don't like I don't like it don't like
I don't like the prisons filled I don't
like this that and then you're going oh
wait this race no wait you know that
race for this thing no this race
no let's see check-cashing Oh Oh your
auntie Mexican families oh that's AB
anti-black ha
there's none I don't we discriminate
against Jews I thought the whole point
is we fuss I hate you yeah I don't know
what happened a Japanese an in an Indian
folk or they just off their off well we
talk about the oppression Olympics a lot
Jews and Asians seem to have been pushed
off and minority groups the I don't
count as minorities I love the fact that
that you know la is 50% Hispanic and 7%
Jew but Jews aren't minorities right
because they're doing so they own the
check-cashing places right so they're
doing well so then you get booted out of
the oppression Olympics someone should
look up the word minority right and see
what that what the definition call him
something else that right I mean I have
gavin newsom on my show and that
two-faced ass wife like literally
brushes his teeth with Brylcreem he
started bringing up check cashing places
and i was like he didn't like the
predatory nature of them and and they
prey on blacks and Hispanics and I said
just blacks and Hispanics and he went
any kind of politician mode you know and
he went know everyone I said everyone
and he said everyone and I said both of
them why you just bringing up blacks and
Hispanics because it's predominantly
black since backs and I said oh ok so it
is black since
oh no well not know but it's everyone
right I said okay so if I go to the
check cashing place I'll find a lot of
Jews everyone
I'll find a lot of Japanese everyone
okay so this one you'll find everyone
but you just brought up these two groups
yeah and then he was like yeah and I was
like all right what are those two groups
doing wrong that they're going to this
check-cashing place and he's like with
nothing they're the best they're the
greatest and I'm like all right so what
is your awesome playing gavin newsom by
the way he's such a two-faced [ __ ]
hypocrite he gavin newsom doesn't give a
[ __ ] about blacks or Hispanics he gives
a [ __ ] about their votes right he had in
my petition
two minute grilling of him had zero
answers as to what could be done about
this place other than shut down check
cashing places so is that just they're
just like it's like saying I want to
close down aids hospices and it's like
no no you should stop aids right not
close down the clinic right that's so
the ISOs listen I'm with you I I hear
you absolutely but I know some people
say this is heartless I don't give a
[ __ ] attack people today yeah that's the
whole thing like the first thing you
have to do is join me in my saying
atheist world that doesn't give a [ __ ]
about what stupid people say about me
yeah I don't care I actually have a plan
to shut down these predatory check
cashing places which is just by having
people not have to go to them ultimately
because you're plenty to fix the thing
man number ones yeah
don't have a bunch of kids you can't
take care of playing to stay intact and
raise your kids
yeah playing three make them breakfast
it's cookies did you make your son
breakfast this morning had the nanny gun
yeah I got back from the check cashing
place yeah what do you like cuz you
don't pay her quite enough to well yeah
she's not you know above what you know
what we had wanted this part out but the
point is yeah um yeah she know he had I
don't know mama made he likes his eggs
basted hasted yeah it's not sunny
side-up it's not over easy it's not
scrambled you see this you grew up in
poverty and now you hear that you're
raising a rich
yeah well back to that I did grow up not
with a dirt floor but poverty
I mean foots welfare and food stamps you
like saying it makes you fight was
father old and I was fine yeah and then
all that work that they always say white
people won't do that's what I did for a
living that's I got out of high school
and I cleaned carpets and I dug ditches
like when they go you'll be digging
ditches like they do it as a metaphor
for you're going nowhere yeah that's
physically you literally did it well
they were I mean to be fair they're not
ditches they're footings or caisson
holes or whatever it is you're doing on
a construction site you're doing a
construction site you're pouring a
footing or you're pouring a grade beam
you got to dig the ditch to pour the
grade beam over the footing or in some
cases if you can't get a caisson rig in
there you got to dig deep enough to pour
a caisson in place and that's we had to
dig it by hand I was down at the bottom
of the thing with like a chipping stick
and a guy had a five-gallon bucket with
a rope on it and I'd fill it with a
sawed-off flathead shovel and then they
tow it up and they'd go up and throw in
a dumpster and and that's what I did and
so I understand when people go uh listen
these poor people they can't eat right
you know they can't do this they can't
feed it yes you can
you have to eat hard-boiled eggs and an
apple I mean it's healthy yeah cheap you
can't eat right this whole notion of
like poor people their morbidly obese
because they have to eat at Wendy's or
whatever no they don't but I I was poor
I would perspire dozen huh
aids and boil um I had a dozen
hard-boiled eggs buy a chub pack of
those mini raisin things I didn't even
have enough money to really eat off the
lunch truck so how are you educated
enough to know that that's what you
should be doing because that's the other
part people they say well they're not
educated enough because look if you get
a happy meal in a college it's now like
eight bucks but for eight bucks at
Trader Joe's yeah you get a dozen eggs
you can get you know a lot of you get
kale a lot of healthy stuff but people
just don't know right so I think the num
is sort of like saying well
outed people in the 80s know that
smoking was bad for you and it's kind of
like that's something need the Surgeon
General a bunch of doctors that you know
r.j. Reynolds bought to tell us it
wasn't it here's how you know cigarettes
are digging people that smoke three
packs they wake up in the morning greet
for a cigarette and here's how you know
it's bad for you there's a stick that
has fire on one end of it and you're
just sucking it's like literally like
living inside of a burning building so
we pretty much the math is there a human
being in modern-day America that sees a
s'more and a stick of celery and goes I
I don't know I guess anyone got a coin
we can toss right out of caloric clerkly
uh I yeah same like no I'd be the press
to know the number of people that
wouldn't know but I'm with you they know
they know everyone else and if ever they
have to know there's there's 5000 PSAs
talking about feed your kids drink water
you know right run around with your kids
read to your kids while they're running
around in drinking water like we're
begging everyone to me no listen I it
like the the deal is I when I work and I
was poor and I worked with other poorest
people these guys when it comes to
lunchtime and they had four bucks are
not going down to Jamba Juice and
spending four bucks on us on a smoothie
with a bunch of kale and beet juice in
it like they're not they're not going to
do that they're going to Taco Bell
because they've been working all day and
they want some beef or something that
smells like beef right that that's
that's what they're going for yeah they
want they want savory now they
understand that what they're doing is
not exactly healthy but they're engaging
in it anyway
and we do this thing where it's like
well it's all about information I feel
like everyone's got them from
Meishan they're choosing its choice not
true not to do it and and somebody needs
first off the school lunch program I was
down with the school lunch program LA
Unified it's prison food it's gelatinous
caloric slot yeah I mean it's square
pizza I don't know why I had to give it
to you in the wrong shape just to like
punish the pork it's like look at pizza
we're gonna give it to you it's gonna be
shaped like a football field right sorry
it was this thick it was dough it had
some kind of mystery meats from yeah
humped on top of it every vegetable
whether it was here the green beans or
corn was Korea war surplus like
literally you know that that feeling
that taste of like this green bean has
been floating in water for so long that
I can only feel it my mouth yeah it's
almost starchy no taste at all like so
we talked about like free this system
and free that free this for first off
you're sending your kids to school and
they're just giving them crap and poison
anyway so how good a parent are you
and then this deal of like hey these
these people can't afford this you want
their kids to go hungry like well first
off the kids 11 and he's 214 pounds so I
don't think he's going hungry then
number two I read a study but I've
always just said it anyway
I don't need studies oatmeal with a
couple of walnuts and a little brown
sugar and some raisins it's 18 cents
pretty good that's basically what it
costs to feed a kid oatmeal one fried
egg and a half Apple one hard-boiled egg
and an orange really okay if that's a
little rich for your blood or a little
too tall in order your kids need to be
removed because here's the deal
uh I will I will turn it back to all the
ass wipes that are watching this who go
huh huh what what okay you [ __ ] you
love nature you love nature I mean
nature number one I forget about God
one else its nature you love nature when
a mama bluej cannot take care of its
chicks cannot feed cannot feed or that
or the or the bear and the cub well it's
never when the cub needs to be removed
when the chick needs to be removed it's
when they can't be fed it's not well the
bear is not reading to its come or it's
ignoring its cub and watching too much
ESPN it's not feeding like the
number-one rule nature is the time the
cub or the chick or the whatever needs
to be removed is when they're not being
fed so I would argue that if you're
incapable of feeding your kids the kids
should be removed
that's number one you know secondhand
smoke and all the other ills of society
are distant second to not feeding your
kid but here's what I know you can't
feed your kid it's your hard-boiled eggs
the night before boil them up next
morning kids going to have an apple a
hard-boiled egg it'll be healthy you'll
feed your kid and here's the better
overall just Gestalt of the whole thing
good word your kid will not be reliant
on the government to feed them and
indoctrinated into this horrific
horrific cult we're starting where the
government's just gonna I was watchin
Hillary Clinton last night and she's
like America you vote me in I got your
back
what the [ __ ] does that even think that
even mean I got your back
yeah all right so let's let's end with
that so the the government oh my
district and ago we did just be you know
we're really not I did not look at any
of those so it was no I wasn't even for
you those are just woster yeah it's
really really bizarre
so wait let's do the lip let's do the
election stubborn boy - yes yeah you can
keep those um he's got a half Jewish
great-grandfather sorry now that is it
just sorry you're in the line of peace
yeah yeah uh so okay so everything I'm
getting from you you basically I think
are a libertarian
so you obviously weren't for Bernie it
doesn't sound like you're for Hillary
you can't be thrilled the Trump right
because no government guy - what are you
gonna do wrong what are you gonna do uh
I guess I got to vote for Trump I don't
know I mean you can't I I can't stand I
was I was listening to Hillary's speech
and her entire speech was had nothing to
do with the economy and had nothing to
do with you know infrastructure or
anything it was just all there peep she
was going to level the playing fields
he's going to love us ago there's a lot
of people all the half knots she was
going to make sure all the have-nots had
theirs I don't know how you can do that
from an oval office let's say 3,000
miles away from where some of those
have-nots are but she was going to make
sure that all the people that didn't
have none of it no part of her speech
talked about rolling up your sleeves
getting to work focusing on the family
you know steering the country back
shrinking the government whatever her
thing was just like everyone with
problems they're over now
just like hope and change yeah nothing
has a hope for what change I don't know
nothing nothing happened I just I'm
tired of politicians that are basically
like spoon-feeding everyone you know
when they do those town halls and
somebody raises their hand and I go I'm
a mother of five I dropped out of high
school I work at it I I work at a
Wendy's what are you gonna do for me
answers nothing you ruined your life you
should have gotten married but know what
one people want waited to have kids yeah
but people want government to replace
God basically right and I think this as
an atheist too so I'm not I'm not
promoting God well no the people the
people want the government to the people
the people the eighth is they want
nature to replace God and they want the
government to fix nature so nature's the
god government fixes nature all is right
the universe that seems like a good
ending you feel good about the ending
there you feel that you feel like that's
a good out Jesus looking at his watch
this Apple watch by the way it looks
like an Apple watch
well you rich elitist yeah we're gonna
put a warning on these videos just to
make it clear cuz I don't want people
walking into this with nothing they
should really understand the wealth so
that when you're talking that you're
really talking down to them not yeah I
am oh that to them directly no no no I
have stupid arguments with everyone all
day about like luck I've just like don't
count on luck make your own luck and
then people tweet me you don't think
luck has something to do and I'm like
why are we even having this discussion
we did just go out go to work oh you
think works hard enough that you know
you can make up what about all those
people that are picking beans in the
field do you think that hard work is
enough and I'm like okay you're super
luck work yeah don't go to work Monday
and just buy lottery tickets and call me
in ten years and tell me how it's going
yeah better yet drive without your seat
belt don't ever put that seat belt on
remember you're lucky when you're going
down to liquor store to buy a lottery
ticket
don't put that seat belt on okay mr.
lucky on that note Adam Carolla I thank
you for coming in and we'll see what we
turn Glendale into I'm gonna I think I
hit them all I think you're on something
we're gonna hit them all
four more of Adams ranting and raving
and literally did not look once at my
swatch Nick is over here you guys can
check out the Adam Carolla podcast at
Adam Carolla com oh and stay tuned for a
huge announcement that I have right here
next week